hi guys tim ferriss here before we get
started a quick announcement have you
ever wished that you could easily access
the best tips tricks tools and tactics
all that alliteration from 200 plus
guests on the Tim Ferriss show that's
about 600 to 700 hours of audio well now
you can and my new book tools of Titan's
does the job it is an inside look at my
favorite advice from the guest on the
podcast people like Arnold
Schwarzenegger who actually wrote the
foreword for the book Jamie Foxx Tony
Robbins
Peter Thiel Amanda Palmer and so many
others and how you can apply their
wisdom to your life and how I've applied
all their advice to mine is at least 50%
new material new tips from old guests
new tips from brand new guests I poured
my heart into this book so if you love
the podcast you will love tools of
Titan's please check it out it helps me
continue to do this podcast pick up your
copy or just read more about it at tools
of titans dot-com and as always thank
you for listening
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking and I don't see the personal
question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by 99designs
when your business needs a logo website
business card thumbnail or any other
design I recommend checking out 99
designs I use them myself I've used them
for many years I use them to create book
cover prototypes for the 4-hour body
which went on to becoming number one
York Times bestseller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
com forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by wealth front and this
is a very unique sponsor wealth front is
a massively disruptive in a good way set
it and forget it investing service led
by technologists from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
take the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not as
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on the show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealth front that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront com forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of
hello ladies and germs boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome back in
my creaky chair to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show as per usual we'll
be discussing the tactics tools habits
of a brilliant individual world-class
performer as I usually say and this is
no exception
you might remember our guest David
Hannah Meyer Hanson often referred to as
DHH from an earlier episode he's back
for round two because his episode is
about to cross a million downloads and
that's in barely two weeks so had to
bring him back you had a million
questions oh he didn't get to last time
if you missed the first round DHH at DHH
on twitter is the creator of Ruby on
Rails he's the co-founder and CTO at
Basecamp formerly known as 37signals
and is the best-selling co-author of
rework and remote subtitle office not
required because three hours wasn't
enough the first time it went really
fast DHH spent another hour answering
your most popular questions most
uploaded questions and this episode he
discusses digital security the value of
schooling three questions you should be
able to answer company culture how the
hell you piss if you are in a 24 hour
car race and much much more so as always
please enjoy this episode with David
Hannah Mayer Hansen shelf and asks what
skills does he think are most important
today is college or graduate degrees
worth it so I have a conflicted
relationship with official schooling
whether that's even high school but
certainly also college and I I used to
have perhaps a more unrefined opinion
off it which was for example as it
pertains to business school that it's so
totally was not worth it
I've come to appreciate some of the
aspects and some of the things that I
was exposed to they're more though over
the years but it's all in the context of
how you acquire that knowledge so for me
in Denmark College is not only free it's
you're getting paid to go you get let's
see if I could do the math in my head
you get like 400 bucks I'm actually won
that 600 bucks a month or something like
that to to go to school maybe even a
little more than that anyway enough that
you can cover almost sort of your basic
living expenses
most people supplement with some work on
the side and I certainly did but it's
not an overwhelming requirement and then
there's also government assisted loans
that have sort of a low cap that won't
track you're in said sort of debt trap
so I'm evaluating my college experience
against that that I came out on the
other side having being paid for the
time I spent there and I did not end up
with a mountain of debt if you do the
same thing in the US and you come out on
the other side with $100,000 or $200,000
or any other amount in in real student
debt these answers might not apply to us
directly and self-study might be a
better answer but what I did like to get
back to the point about my college
exposure was all the things that I
perhaps wouldn't just have gotten into
on my own I got a good basic
understanding of organizational theory
organizational models and mass lafe's
theory and all these sort of the the
basic Canon of Business Administration
and the world that it is and where we
ended up with how to run a scam was in
many ways the opposite right like we we
didn't follow the prescriptions many of
the prescriptions but knowing about them
was actually helpful in establishing
where we would choose to be different
and where we wouldn't where we wouldn't
have to invent the deep dish again and
we could just follow tradition and where
we totally went well tradition is stupid
I gave a talk at the Stanford Business
School quite a few years ago now called
unlearn your MBA because what I got was
part of an MBA lots of overlapping
theory on both economics and
organizational theory and lots of the
things that I learned
I'm glad that when I learned them I
wasn't an impressionable 18 year old I
think that's one of the other
differences about going to college in
the u.s. versus in Denmark I didn't go
to college right away I stayed out of
school for three or four years after
high school and worked in the Internet
industry which was just enough time to
get me totally jaded about
organizational theory and innovation and
disruption and all these other keywords
and buzzwords that would then be thrown
around in business school with a serious
face
I was jaded enough to have a very
critical mind so I wasn't being
programmed I was trying to filter
everything that I learned through the
lens of real life and real experiences
and that made it much more effective I
think in terms of figuring out what
should stick and what shouldn't stick
and what should I not just have a
skeptical opinion about but being direct
opposition to and I find that that's a
great way to define who you are and what
you believe is not just the positive
things I am for this but also I'm
against this I want to do the opposite
of that I think I actually learned more
from Business School by saying oh yeah
all these things I'm not gonna do that
we're not gonna work like that I think
that's still bitter meaner bad in any
form and we're gonna do something else
so I think that that really was worth it
and and so was the exposure to
philosophy and I'd say where I got the
least out of it actually was on the
computer science part as I said it was
joint degree in computer science and
Business Administration and the computer
science part just was I found more value
in self-study I think the opportunities
that we had even at that time early
2000s of open source software and
tinkering on your own and building your
own systems was a much better way for me
to learn in large part because I learned
my technical things or skills
through using them in anger it wasn't
like I sat down for a lecture and then
like oh yeah okay I wonder how I can use
this one day no no it was trying to
build this specific thing what do we
need to learn to do that so that worked
really well for the specific technical
attributes of it but that doesn't work
that well for philosophy right like it's
harder to figure out what you don't know
about what you don't know right and
getting exposed to the disciplines of
liberal arts and life in that sense was
really helpful the same actually goes
for economics and organizational theory
that there are some practical theories
and models and ways of thinking that you
may not want to use them but your mind
is better by knowing them I guess I mean
I shouldn't slander programming computer
scientists totally in that boat there's
also plenty of value and computer
science about knowing different models
and paradigms of thought if you know a
functional programming versus procedural
programming an object-oriented
programming understanding sort of the
broad tectonic plates in your domain is
definitely very helpful so I've warmed
up to schooling over time and perhaps
part of that is because I realized more
of its stuck than I thought
that I would sit through some lecture
and I think during the lecture Jesus
this is stupid I'm never gonna use this
and years later it would come up that oh
that's actually similar to that one
thing and I would have meat have
knowledge of which thread to pull on
further like I wouldn't necessarily
remember the whole lecture but I've know
where to go to learn more and inform
myself more about these things so I
think the main value there is just
opening your mind to a broader window on
the world and brought a window on life
to be honest especially as it comes to
these softer skills it's stem is a big
rah-rah moment for a lot of people in
technology and lots of people make fun
of history or philosophy or languages
and so on and I go like you're all my
number one take away from going to
college and spending time there and so
on was to come out on the other side not
as a more efficient worker but as a
better human as a more well-rounded
human being for a long life and that
notion of the long life is think is
quite accurate I threw several times
during the three-year degree where I
went like oh [ __ ] I'm wasting my time
but you know what really over three
years compared to what the next 80 it's
probably limits to just how much I'm
wasting my time and when there weren't
limits when I really thought something
was a complete and other waste of time I
just wouldn't pay attention I'd just
accept my bad grades and I'd spent that
time on something else and that was
wonderful too but yeah there we go
rodolfo G and asks the state to believe
that self writing code will be a reality
soon ai writing its own code like Skynet
if so when would that be it's a really
interesting question that traces back a
long time when I was going through
business school I have a joint degree in
computer science at business school one
of the things we looked at at the time
was something called case tools where
you would basically outline your
requirements for a piece of software and
then the software would try to figure
out how to write that piece of code for
you and that has a long tradition going
back 90s and the 80s where people
thought oh we're just in the cusp of
figuring out when humans don't need to
know to code anymore and we will then
arrive at a place where they can just
describe their requirements and voila
the software will be produced for them
and I can totally see the appeal of that
obviously right and we have moved there
to some extent computer programming
started as a
assembler and punch
in a very low-level way of describing
your program until we build abstraction
upon abstraction upon abstraction on top
of it and now today we're sitting with
software and environments like Ruby
where you are describing what you want
to happen at a very high level right but
obviously that's still a fair jump to
just a natural English description of a
software so that's where it really
breaks down for me or that's why I don't
see computer ridden software as
something that's just around a corner
because writing software's really are
about making decisions and you can
really only have something
auto-generated for you if you're willing
to cede a certain set of decisions and
we've already gotten pretty good I'd say
and building those abstraction levels up
to a point where the decisions we're
left to deal with and certainly this is
my aspiration with Ruby on Rails are the
decisions we care about if you find a
set of decisions that you just don't
care about you just don't care about how
that level of the code is implemented
well then you can abstract and build on
top of it but you can't just say to a
computer hey can you make me a base camp
it needs to have messages and some chat
and blah blah blah blah blah right
because you're not gonna get the base
camp that we have the base camp that we
have is the product of tens of thousands
of little decisions that all at least in
our eyes matter because if they didn't
matter then someone else would have have
to figure that out which I guess it's a
little bit like if you're not writing
your own software if you're asking
someone else to write yourself where for
you you you kind of try to do this right
you pretend that you can tell another
group of people through a set of
requirements can you build me this thing
and then they'll build you something
that's close enough to what you want to
ask most programmers a designer is how
well that typically goes it's a very
painful process for a lot of consultants
and people who live off trying to
implement other people's requirements
because it's a really fussy project
process it's
fussy to narrow down what it is that you
really want and it turns out certainly
for us when we software builders the
thing that we really want is is there
was ten thousand decisions all made
right it's not just one or two or three
things so even if we could get to the
point where hey I could write software
on its own how would we specify the
requirements that's that's where it
really stops for me again that doesn't
mean this won't happen and maybe AI will
become so smart as to be basically that
black box and perhaps we won't get
exactly the software that we want but
it'll be close enough and it'll be so
much more efficient I don't see that as
around the corner and by around the
corner I mean 10 20 years funnily enough
of course that has been the horizon for
AI in general it seems for about the
existence of computer science that
perhaps even before that that we thought
oh yeah we're just like 10 or 20 years
away from having this AI and if you look
at what AI is today I think that's a
very flattering term for a lot of
systems that really aren't that smart
try to talk to your Amazon echo or
Google home and pretty quickly the
Turing test breaks down or rather just
fails it right so who knows what's gonna
happen in 30 years I don't think anyone
can predict that but I don't see it on
the closer rise and I don't see wanting
it as long as I care about all the
thousands of little decisions that go
into it because I think we've arrived at
a point where there are plenty of
decisions I don't care about I don't
care about decisions about memory
management largely speaking until it's a
major issue and it very rarely isn't the
kind of work that I do so I can abstract
myself from say releasing memory by hand
as you used to do in some program
languages that are closer to the metal
so to speak Martin shorter asks what are
his thoughts on building a company
culture
culture is one of those words that
gotten almost too tainted to be useful
because culture is now sort of slogan
for all sorts of [ __ ] and cultures a
ping-pong table culture is a mission
statement cultures all these external
artifacts which may be those are results
of culture I don't think their culture
itself I think far more interesting
definition of culture is the things that
we do over and over again and it's hard
to just write that up before and say
these are the things we're going to be
because what happens off is of course
you don't live up to that stuff I find
the definition of culture far more
interesting as a historical expedition
almost like these are the things that we
do so you start doing a bunch of things
as a company and your definition of
culture should be a retrospective of
what are those things what are we doing
as a company in it as the culture that
we have and do we like that so culture
becomes an iterative process where you
keep looking back and what you did and
then you make changes when you see
things you don't like and we certainly
had a lot of that at base camp over the
years where we would look back at
certain policies or certain ways we were
doing things and say like yeah that's
currently part of our culture but
they're not flattering parts of the
culture so let's change them and then we
would have other parts of the culture
and go like hey that's really working
like we should do more of that and not
only should we do more of that we should
spread that as a gospel to other
companies such that they too can benefit
from this aspect of our culture and
that's what the books that we wrote
remote and rework are about they're
taking the aspects of culture that
Basecamp had and have and say we can
share those with other people in sort of
snippets and we can say okay we're going
to have a culture of no overwork we're
not going to have a culture of
workaholics in fact in rework we say
fire the workaholics so we want to have
a place of work where 40 hours and less
is what's expected of people so that
becomes part of our culture or is part
of our culture and then we sort of
observe that and then extract it I think
there are times where we say okay we
have some aspirations but they're based
off again history of us looking at
things we're doing and saying that's not
working we want to do something else but
it doesn't really become part of the
culture before we actually do that I
think a lot of people think that you can
just describe this utopia that you want
oh that's your culture like we ascribe
to be the best in quality like we're all
about quality well that's a meaningless
tape it's a worse than a meaningless
statement if it's not true there's
nothing worse for the integrity of a
culture than a description of culture
that does not match it is incredibly
corrosive to have company leaders or
company descriptions that do not mirror
reality we just stumbled into this again
at base can when we hit 50 people and we
realize that in addition to all the
books we've written so on there are
still all matters of culture and
practical perceptions of things at
Basecamp that are hard for a new person
who comes in a new hire to learn in a
quick order that we have a very much an
oral culture at Basecamp and a
historical culture where we did things
at certain points and like that formed
part of our ethos but that takes a long
time to adopt as someone new so we
taught to make things a little more
explicit and we wrote up an employee
handbook and that employee handbook
included all sorts of different aspects
of prescriptive culture but the most
important I think was a warning saying
if you're finding things in your actual
work that does not match this
description of things you have to stand
up and say so
that we will not become a company and
again that's perhaps more prescription
again and descriptor although I don't
know I'm flattering myself and that's
always easy to do but I'd like to think
that we do sort of try to live that that
even when we have aspirations and we
don't live up to those aspirations we're
honest about it and we can talk about
how we failed such that we can get
closer and try again and we already got
feedback on that we wrote things up in
that employee handbook where someone new
joined the company and said like you
know what that's not my experience
that's not what I saw and I find that
that's just one of those unique
beautiful gifts that new employees and
new eyes can give you that they see
things much closer to how they really
are than the people who've been steeped
in the culture for a long time and have
sort of just accepted all the illusions
and solutions that build up over time
when you get someone with fresh eyes in
they can just go like hello guys this
doesn't mean this isn't right this isn't
working or this isn't clear or or on the
flip side this is really working like
wow you guys are really different when
it comes to this one aspect I hadn't
lived through that before I think we
have a fair amount of that at base camp
to where we need essentially cultural
reprogramming from especially for people
who've worked in more corporate
environments that base camp is quite
different from those environments and it
can be hard when you transplant from one
culture to another a lot of it is not
just about learning the new culture it's
about unlearning the old culture and you
have to respect that and you have to
give that some time and you have to be
explicit about how those transitions
happen and to say that they matter and I
think that that's sometimes the economy
that companies and people find
themselves stuck between is that either
they're paying lip service to culture
and culture as a ping-pong table and
culture is a mission statement or slogan
or they go over in the other digits they
like culture doesn't matter at all like
it's
just about the work which is funny
enough one of the aspects of our culture
and sort of a different area of the
company but culture is real and it
matters and you can't just program it
upfront like it has to be run it has to
be actually lived to be real Nate Berkus
asks what things does he do to ensure
his digital security password managers
etc this is one of the things I've
gotten a lot more interested in over the
years when I started with computers I
was completely ignorant of security and
sort of thought that it was overstated
and who would want to know my secrets
would want to read my email and I think
even though before just starting to hear
about I think people getting hacked or
getting this sense that this is real and
then I think of course Snowden and his
revelations about how governments around
the world or in particularly in the u.s.
or invading everyone's security and
privacy really brought things to the
forefront and I think we've gotten and
I've gotten a lot more serious about
insuring things
mail or other insecure ways so for the
specifics I use one password I use one
password both personally and with my
wife and at the company and that's not a
perfect story I think password managers
especially the ones that share things
through syncing still have ways to go
but it's way better than trying to
either a remember a thousand different
passwords which no one does anyway or
just use a small handful of passwords
that you keep reusing over and over
again so that was a pretty mmm not that
reason but a few years ago that
switching to a password manager I had
some passwords for an embarrassingly
long amount of time and just seeing site
after site getting hacked really brought
that to the forefront on top of that of
course encrypt everything this notion
that when you turn off your
computer or even it goes to sleep in the
same with your phone that it could be
lost is such a revelation I remember
when in college someone would lose their
laptop and they'd go like oh [ __ ] I like
I lost all my stuff like that person
that got it is gonna have access to all
my stuff I which is just a terrible
terrible thing I think we've really
moved forward as a society by now you
can lose your computer or your phone and
it doesn't mean losing all your data to
some criminal and not worrying about
who's going through your photos who's
going through your emails or whatever
else so encryption on all the things I
find it really disappointing to be
honest that when you buy a new Mac a
full disk encryption is still not turned
on it's something that everyone should
turn on immediately if they haven't and
that doesn't just go for laptops but it
also goes for your desktop computers
people have their house is broken into
all the time so go to a system
preferences security and privacy and
then file fault and look to see whether
that's turned on and if it's not turned
on turn it on immediately two-factor
authentication is another huge one
especially on your email account if you
have an email account right now that's
only secured by a password especially if
that's not a strong password it's just
the one you remember you're just just
waiting to get screwed because if
someone gets into your email account
then they have access to everything
generally speaking they can reset your
password on any other site and they can
get it to anything and you will be owned
and it will be very very painful so I
use Gmail and use their two-factor
authentication which basically just
means when I'm trying to log into Gmail
on the new computer or occasionally I
need a second device I need my phone to
get a code and then I can log in from
there so that's been a few step up I've
turned that off everywhere you can turn
it on certainly turn it on for things
like your bank and your email and I have
it on for Twitter and you turn it on for
your Apple ID and you turn it off
basically anywhere you can and now it's
at the point where
if a site doesn't have to obey I'm like
[ __ ] I hope I don't have to put anything
important in here I'm really glad that
we got to a PHA into base camp
quite a few years ago because I wouldn't
feel good about using a service or I had
to store important information without
to a PHA there and it's still shocking
to me that to this day and age I'll
still sign up for a new service and
maybe they won't even have to avait but
they'll also put [ __ ] restrictions
on your password like oh it has to be
you're only 12 characters and like what
I'm using one password I'm using a
password manager let me have my 25
character mixed password and and put
that in there so yeah encryption and two
of eight and a password manager I think
that's sort of the basic trifecta that
if you don't have those things in place
right now get them not just for the sake
of if you should get hacked but also
just for the sake of insuring than the
governments around the world have access
to less of your stuff
same goes obviously for instant
messaging use iMessage use whatsapp or
even better use signal don't use things
that send things clear text or only
encrypted in transit like Google's
offerings they have to have a special
setting turned on for you to have the
things encrypted I think that's terrible
don't use that if you can avoid it and
yeah I take those there at those top
things Levi Belknap asks how did he and
Jason freed make the tough decisions to
sell off the portfolio of products
37signals created high-rise no your
company backpack can't fire and so on
when Ari parented a Space Camp and
double down on that product I'm
especially interested in the process
they used to think about the decision
and the forces that place at played that
they were facing
yes this was an interesting time for
base camp I think we were around or just
under 30 people and we were starting to
feel stretched thin we had four plus
products for major products and a lot of
other psyche chefs going at the time and
we had fallen into this habit of
basically just thinking yeah we're okay
with high rise right now for example
let's just put that on the shelf for six
months or perhaps even longer and then
we'll just focus on backpack will focus
on base camp and this rotation just
meant that our products would kind of
just languish for some time and you
don't feel it right away customers
generally speaking wouldn't really
complain like oh there hasn't been any
new features for six months but it would
still seep in and worst of all we felt
bad about it we didn't feel we were
doing our products justice that there
was more that we could do and feel
better about if our first instinct we
were more people so that led to the
discussion of hey we're thirty or forty
people right now we have to be a lot
more like if we have four major products
and we all want to do it injustice and
we want to make native apps for all of
them we want to do really good design
that we think through we want to do
everything to the peak of our abilities
the best products that we can make right
the best software that we know how
that's not possible with the company we
have today so we face the natural
I don't even call it dilemma because for
most people is not a dilemma for most
companies it's not dilemma what you see
is hey you have profitable products they
need more people and just hire more
people that's the natural conclusion
right well not for us we've always
wanted to stay a small company and for
me in particular I didn't want to run a
big company I didn't want to run a
company of hundreds of people
and I saw just to jump that if we went
from let's say 30 or 40 people
to eighty or a hundred people we'd
already be down that path of no return
that we could not then prevent the whole
thing for ballooning ever further from
there and then we'd be a hundred people
then we'd be two hundred people and I
would wake up in the morning thinking
why am I doing this do I really want to
keep doing this and I'm quite sure my
answer would have been no so that led me
to the obvious conclusion that the
natural path of expansion the natural
path of just hiring more people to deal
with more work would lead to a place
where I wouldn't want to be interested
in this work anymore I would want to get
out as so many people who work with
startups and new companies do they
realize that they enjoy working with
companies of a certain size let's say 50
people lasts or 30 people or less and
then they just go with the flow and then
they end up with a large company and
they think oh okay it's it's time to
start over well I didn't want that so we
had some pretty heated discussions for a
while we have to pretty the suggestions
were Jason in particular accurately said
like hey we have these principles of
wanting to make the best products and
work of our life and we cannot do that
if we're stretched so thin so we need
more people otherwise we can't do it and
me going like yeah but no I don't want
to run a big company push push push push
push push
well Jason then called a small group of
us together in Chicago to think about a
big alternative and that big alternative
of course was becoming Basecamp that we
would take all these additional products
that we have all these extracurricular
activities that were spreading us so
thin and we would simply get rid of them
not get rid of them as just flushed him
down the toilet but get rid of them as
in spinning them off as we did with no
your company and high rise to great
effect or roll it into the main product
as we did with campfire or even just
shut it down in the sense of not
accepting new customers as we did with
backpack
and we just sat at that meeting and
thought like yes this is the right thing
to do it's not the economically right
thing to do we could certainly have been
better off and had a bigger business if
we would just to sit you know what we're
just gonna hire a bunch more people and
we're gonna direct those people to keep
improving all products at the same time
with no stalls and stops but why we're
already a big enough company we're
already making enough money Jason and I
are interested in Basecamp
because we want to be here for the rest
of our working life like that's been the
goal from the get-go that we wanted to
design a company that we would be
comfortable working at not just
comfortable but happy working at for the
rest of our lives so that's how you get
to these weird conclusions where you go
like hey we have this awesome
profitable business let's take high-rise
for example high-rise was almost at the
level were high-rise alone we could have
run the whole company off that and we
went like well we're gonna spin it off
we're not gonna work on it anymore
backpackers had made millions of dollars
we basically said do you know what that
was a great run it's now behind the
times we're gonna we're gonna Park it
we're gonna make it part of our legacy
and as part of that legacy we came up
this the saying that we're gonna keep
things around until the end of the
internet that someone for example who
used to backpack was not gonna wake up
one morning to a sunset they're not
gonna wake up to a fake sunset as it
always is of course right like some sort
of like oh it's been an incredible
journey now pack your [ __ ] and get out
of here because backpack is shutting
down I had seen all sorts of companies
from Google Google Reader and and many
others countless up there's almost all
others working in our industry when they
decided they didn't want to work on
something anymore they just pulled the
plug and users be damned and workflows
be damned and that was just was nuts we
still to this day have people using
backpack we still to this day have
people using technology
was a simple to-do list
we launched in 2005 and shut down under
a couple years later and we still have
people using it and I'm really proud of
that I'm proud of the fact that we years
and years and years and years later can
maintain our legacy while still having
one major focus Basecamp that one
product so those are some of the
dynamics that are going on at the time
and I think looking back at it now I
just go like of course of course we
should have done that of course this was
the right answer
of course we actually went too long but
that's how things change in business
where we started out with the idea we
didn't know the base camp which is gonna
take off like this we didn't know that
basically we're just gonna keep on
growing and growing and growing growing
as it has so when we started out we were
hedging our beds we launched other
products in part thinking what Basecamp
might just be a fluke it might just go
out of business and we better have some
other ideas and that's a good strategy I
think in the beginning as we were
hedging our bets but then one of the
bets just turned out to pay off so
spectacularly that was almost negligent
to keep that strategy keep that original
hedging bet strategy we needed to double
down and the thing that was clearly
working so much better than everything
else
lest we let that slip through our
fingers so there it was Levi's Belknap
also asks he and Jason are both very
opinionated have they how have they
managed their relationship as
co-founders especially being remote can
you share a story about the biggest
fights they've had as co-founders and
how they resulted general rules and
processes to use when managing
disagreement and conflict in their
relationship sometimes things get heated
I think things get heated usually
actually when we talk about specific
product things specific ways of
attacking features or how to prioritize
things and we see things differently but
that heat dissipates credibly quickly
between Jason and I it's a because we
always come back to the fundamentals to
fundamentally shared principles we have
the kind of company we want to build and
for the kind of product that we want to
build so when you sort of strip things
back to first principles and see like
wait a minute how deep does this
disagreement go we find that most of our
disagreements actually lay at the
surface and if you just keep digging and
you keep scratching as we talked about
on the podcast then you find the common
ground it might just be buried a little
further down but it's there because if
it's not there then you have deeper
problems anyway right like then things
wouldn't last for this long but on top
of that we've used all sorts of specific
tactics to resolve these surface
tensions and one of the tactics that I
particularly like and we've used for a
long time is who cares most so when we
go into a disagreement sometimes if you
can but get pretty hot but usually
there's one person who cares more than
the other person and we've just set up a
give-and-take system where whoever cares
most if the discussion goes long wins
that means that sometimes I can care a
fair amount about something and then
just still say all right I'm gonna let
it go Jason you do it and then he does
it and then the next time perhaps I'm
the one who cares the most and then we
go with my side of things and the
majority of the time we then argue argue
argue get heated heated heated then
everything calms down we perhaps take a
day away from it come back to it and
then we're all in the same pace page so
even those areas times where we have to
basically just concede a point they're
pretty rare and when they're happen it's
fine it'll play fine over 12 years
you'll have some I'll have some
everything will be just fine
another tactic to use when you have
disagreement is who's gonna do the work
if I have strong opinions about how a
piece of design is supposed to be
implemented well if it's Jason who
actually has to do the work and Corral
the troops designers that he's working
with well he just has a natural
advantage here he has naturally higher
ground doesn't mean he's always right it
doesn't mean we'll always go that way
but I'll concede the point more often
than not when it falls
into his specific wheelhouse which is
designed same thing goes with
programming we talks about lots of
features in Basecamp where it's mostly a
technical challenge and ask the
technical person or the programmer of
the two of us I get to have the higher
ground when it comes to technical
matters so I think we have a great
respect mutual respect for that
expertise that each of us hold well then
of course we also have the overlap areas
words about generally running the
company or marketing or anything else
like that we can't you really use higher
ground in those scenarios because it's
more even ground we're being met on but
that also means that either we use that
other principle of who cares more about
it or as it happens in most cases
neither of us end up being that
passionate that if you talk about it for
just a little while longer then it
resolves itself and finally I'd say we
employ the same tactic that we encourage
everyone at the company to employ which
is to stop talking and start making when
we have disagreements about which way to
go just trying it usually resolves
things very quickly so if it's about a
feature in Basecamp
then you have to implement it and see
how it feels and see how it works
if it's about a marketing strategy just
find the smallest way you can get a
disprovable test going and then try it
and if we if I think something is not
gonna work and we try it and it doesn't
work okay so what what we wasted a
little bit of time we wasted a little
bit of money no big deal if we try
something I don't think it's going to
work and it works again I win so if you
look at it from that perspective you can
quote unquote win you can get to the
great outcome in all cases whether
you're right or whether you're wrong you
still win if you're right then we don't
carry on with that idea if you're wrong
then hey that great idea made it through
even with your position Levi's Belknap
asks David his proud father I would love
to hear about his most important lessons
learned the things he does
farther that work well for him is his
children how does he know that he's
being a good father
how does he measure himself well we
talked about this at some length on the
podcast but I look at this on the broad
scale at the top level in much the same
way look at everything else which I'm
sure is a limitation and I have one pair
of glasses to see most of the world
which is how would I feel if I was in
cold shoes I for whatever reason have a
pretty good memory of what it was like
being a four-year-old and the things
that I found unreasonable so it to me
it's not that much of a stretch to put
me myself in Colt shoes and to see where
things go from there so I try to think
about things from that ankle is this
reasonable or this is not reasonable and
even when it's not reasonable which is a
lot of times when you're dealing with
three and four-year-olds or smaller kids
can we just let it play out anyway like
what's the worst that can happen here if
the worst that can happen is Colt is
going to get materially hurt as in
broken bones and blood spouting all over
the place and or death okay I you don't
get to call make that call right if you
can just get a little bit hurt like you
can bang your head or you can scratch
your knee or whatever fine experience
that on your own self see how it goes if
you want to stay up past quote-unquote
your bedtime which is this things that
adult impose on kids to tell them when
it's convenient for the adults to go to
sleep fine you can do that you can
choose on your own and sometimes I'll
say like if you want to just keep being
on your iPad you can do that you just
you get to sit in the living room by
yourself I'm going to bed because I
cherish and value my sleep immensely so
if it's if it's time to me to go to bed
anyway well I'm just going to do that
and you can figure out what you want to
do and what usually happens is he'll
continue playing for another 10-15
minutes and then he will want to go to
sleep too so I think there's a lot of
wins to be had we
and you don't have to win everything and
you don't have to win right now and you
accept that kids are not only people but
that they have to form their own
first-hand experiences can't tell a kid
in most cases that oh well if you eat
another gummy bear you're gonna have a
tummy ache much better for him to just
coughs Elf on Gorge himself on those
gummy bears and get that tummy ache and
learn for himself that like eating a
whole bag like isn't that great same
thing with the sleep thing if he wakes
up and he's tired in the morning well
there's some feedback getting those
firsthand feedback loops playing is a
far better strategy in my mind than
trying to teach them teaching those
things don't really work that well I
find what you can do is offer commentary
suggestions and so forth such that not
that they'll work in the moment but that
when the natural feedback loop plays out
perhaps it'll ring a bell like oh
actually he said something about like me
being tired if I stay up all night or
I'll have a tummy ache if I eat this or
some ways for Colt to put things into
perspective once he gets those
consequences and smacking in the face of
himself right so how does that really
play into measuring yourself as a good
father is there a scoreboard you can
keep probably not you probably won't
know to large extent like you'll know
the first hand responses right like
you'll know whether you're having a good
time and a good relationship in the
moment do you know how that's gonna play
out over the next 20 years no you don't
so you have to sort of just go with with
your best judgment on that and my best
judgment is how would I feel in his
shoes and is this reasonable can we just
let it play out can we just let it slide
which I'm sure for many parents not only
am I sure witness and heard it from
other parents
sounds like overly permissive and lacks
and all sorts of other things you know
what I'm okay with that if for no other
reason that one
the guiding principles I have would Colt
is how to raise a rebel I do not want a
compliant kid a lot of parenting is
about having compliant kids will do what
they are told and sit still when you
asked him to and be proper and blah blah
blah know what that's not that high on
my list of priorities this came to the
forefront in part when we tried a
Montessori School of all things in Spain
and we thought at first while Jaime had
read up a bunch of Montessori and she'd
give me a good recounted this sounds
great like this sounds much better than
traditional schooling in playtime and so
on so we take three-year-old colt there
and he absolutely just hates it right he
absolutely hates it cries and cakes and
screams like don't wanna don't go don't
wanna go it's not the first day not just
the second day for like a week and a
half and after we can half we're like
this is not getting better what is going
on here
and then we had some conversations with
the specific school they're like oh no
it's gonna be okay but like let me tell
you a little bit about our school our
number one word here is respect and I
just went like [ __ ] of course that's not
gonna work really you're number one word
for three-year-olds is respect as in
that they should respect their teachers
and they should respect the rules and
like yes this is not gonna work
we are otherwise following path here on
how to raise a ripple and that's just
not a good fit for our kid so we learned
from that that even if you think like oh
they have all the right wooden toys with
no bad paint and they can play out in
the yard and so on there's some
structural frameworks about how teachers
and adults think about their
relationship to kids that are very much
at odds with different ways of thinking
so this is one of those cases where we
went this is not the right thing for our
family and then we put called in a
basically play school where there was no
structured learning where all he did all
day was run around on these little
motorcycles and play with kids in the
yard and sort of paint
and other things that were not
structured in the same sense and he
loved it and had a great time and I
thought like hey we did a good job as
parents here I think we did not subject
our kid to just like you have to
continue doing this even if you hate it
for weeks on end just because we think
this is the right thing for you truly
some Madison has self opinion as a kid
smarter than the rest different not
really hmm when I think back I
definitely had lots of domains where I
certainly did not feel smart and
ironically enough the one I ended up
doing professionally programming was one
of those because most of the time
growing up I had older friends and they
were into computers and quite a few of
them programmers and they were really
good so what I saw was this huge jump in
skill that just seemed insurmountable
for me that this was not me I couldn't
do those things in part because I tried
somewhat a little bit and hadn't
succeeded on the first go as though
anyone ever does but then I saw the
comparison to these friends I had who
were just really good what they were
doing and I thought like geez this is
too hard
like I got to do something else so I
never had this I'm smarter than everyone
else what I did have though was an
innate sense that if a large enough
group of people can figure this out so
can I like I'm not dumber than everyone
else that's for sure
I don't sort of ascribe to like oh yeah
I'm just dummy I can't figure this out
no no I can figure this out if I apply
myself well enough to it I'm not gifted
with something special here I don't have
like some innate talent to do this that
gives me a leg up and some domains I
thought like yeah maybe I could become a
programmer but I'm just not gonna put
into time that looks really really hard
and I could spend my time on other
things that perhaps look easier to me
and I'll try my hand of those first so
it was kind of a dichotomy between
thinking like I'm not actually
good at a bunch of things but at the
same times I can also become good enough
if I just apply myself and when it came
to programming then it was an
interesting switch when I then learned
how to program and again I didn't think
of myself as program when I first
learned to program
then I started working in open-source
and then after a couple of years I got
exposed enough to see that the code that
I was putting out and the way I was
running projects what's working that was
really a comparison that wasn't
available in the same way before the
internet and before open-source and
before getting involved with all those
things I didn't have a good way of
measuring my progress I would just
measure my progress against books or my
own sense of self-worth and that wasn't
always in tune so for a long time I did
absolutely did not have any delusions
that I was doing anything that
noteworthy it wasn't until I got a
chance to compare myself openly against
a lot of other people and a lot of other
projects and a lot of other code that I
thought like oh wait a minute this isn't
too shabby after all the same went with
things like driving a race car like when
I first started to drive I thought like
oh geez I'm actually not that good at
this I'm finishing quite far down the
totem pole but a lot of that was paying
myself early against people were just
really good I think it's um otherwise
easy to fall into the trap where you're
just comparing yourself to some little
local circle and thinking like oh I'm
the best of my local gang at either
programming or playing Magic the
Gathering or Mortal Kombat or the
racetrack and then resting assured and
happy and satisfied with that as we've
talked about earlier that was never that
never had an appeal to me so I'd rather
they just think like eight I'm no
different than anyone else but if I
apply myself hard enough not so much
just through like oh you're just gonna
put in hard work but
I don't even it's it's hard to find the
right words for this because you did not
want to say like Oh be smart enough
about it but that's a Miss known to
because this is just that I didn't think
about myself as particularly smart but I
did think that there are ways of
learning that are smart it's not so much
that I'm smart but that there are some
smart techniques and I can just pull
those techniques off the shelf and I can
apply them and I can end up in a
different place through that Ian McCrae
asks how does he prep for them all how
does he stay alert behind the wheel for
such long periods of time so Lamont is a
24-hour race in France that happens once
a year it's a whole week of fun and game
and exhausting times they start by doing
the scrutineering as it's called the
check of the cars the technical check
that they develop told your regulations
in the town centre on like the Sunday
and then the race is that Saturday so
it's a really long week and it's a
really exhausting time and you do have
to prepare for that and it's a
interesting sort of way that you do
prepare one of the greatest way I think
to prepare for LeMond it's just to a
bunch of racing before it there really
is no other exercise like actually being
on a race track that will stand in for
that that doesn't mean that that's the
only thing you do usually in a head of
every season I have a fairly rigorous
training program maybe three times a
week I certainly did this year where I
worked with a personal trainer for one
hour three times a week and we do
strength training and we do endurance
training and so forth just to have a
general good fitness level that's
certainly important it's certainly
important to just be in a good shape I
don't take it that extreme I mean there
are definitely professional drivers
certainly the ones that race in the top
prototype class that one p one that has
the toughest physical requirements that
do just intensive non-stop training and
the bike and do all these other things
while I'm not a full-time athlete that's
to be honest I don't I don't enjoy it
that much I exercise because I know it's
good for me
I know afterwards that it feels better I
know that I'm gonna be a sort of been
better overall shape not just physically
but mentally as a human being and
because I want things I want to be
competitive at the mall so these are the
things I have to do and I've just found
that those things just don't happen
automatically for me I'm not the person
who's just like says oh there's an hour
let me just go work out so that's where
having a trainer and working on
appointment with something which someone
has been really helpful to me so I do
that and then it's the funny thing with
LeMond is that a lot of it is still
mental - it's not just about the
physical preparation for it I've seen
plenty of drivers were in great physical
condition still absolutely bomb at Lamar
because they just can't keep the mental
game together and part of the mental
game is if you're leading if you're
posted meeting is the pressure of not
making a mistake for that many hours
just going round round and round going
to get to you are you trying to reach
too high and for too much since that you
get yourself into one of those mistakes
there's a lot of patience to be played
and it's easy to have that patience
perhaps in the first into the second
stint but perhaps a little harder to
have that later in the game and that's
when a lot of people make mistakes you
also of course have the fact that it is
24 hours and when you say 24 hours it's
not really 24 hours it's more like 36
hours or 40 hours because you get up
pretty early that morning the race
doesn't start until 3 o'clock so you've
already been up for a long time by the
time the race starts so there's just a
lot of sleep deprivation that actually
goes into that specific day on top of
the fact that you've already been a
dilemma for a whole week and that's
tough and that's physical and that's
challenging so you just have to bring
that in because the actual time when you
sit in the car and you're going at it
adrenalin just kicks in it doesn't
really matter how tired you are like
it's not like you'll have trouble
keeping your eyes awake going 300
kilometres now
I've had that driving a normal streetcar
where you just go I am too tired to
actually do that no matter how much will
I apply to this problem it's really hard
for me to stay awake you don't really
have that same problem in a racecar
thankfully you could say I've never
heard of someone falling asleep at the
wheel when you're actually going at it
things just happen too quickly but that
can sometimes give you a false sense of
security that just because you can keep
your eyes open that your mind is open to
and that you're making all the
adjustments to your routine as
circumstances demand them because
driving around a racetrack for 24 hours
it means that the track changes you have
all sorts of things people go off track
people were not dude they pull on gravel
onto the track you have to make constant
alterations so you have to not just be a
weight but be have an open mind to
changing things and changing things up
and I think that is probably one of the
hardest things for a lot of drivers that
just keeping in that open mode not just
putting it on autopilot because they're
not a pilot that's when you make a
mistake and the next time you come
around for some corner there's a car
that's tracked something onto the track
or the track itself just changes over
the 24 hours it changes immensely more
Robert goes down or if you have whether
any of these other things so that's some
of the considerations I put into it that
is why I think Lamont is the greatest
race in the world because it brings
these challenges you don't usually feel
when you do a six hour racer or 45
minute race for that matter it's a
unique challenge to make no mistakes and
stay on your game for 24 hours
Stuart Howard Smith's asks where do you
take a piss when racing a 24 hour a limo
race well in the seat that's is the
honest truth I have never in my six
years of racing hat to pee that bad and
I went in my seat but I guarantee you
that had lots and lots of drivers have I
was just actually in the ten hour race
in the u.s. a couple months ago and my
co-driver got damn peed in the seat and
he was in the start of his stint he's
been out for an hour and I think the
realization that he had to be in the car
for another two
half-hours he just went [ __ ] it I'm
peeing in my seat and of course the team
is laughing and laughing and laughing
and why are they laughing well they
don't have to go into the seat after him
I had to go into the seat after him and
the guy one of the mechanics would go oh
you're gonna have such a monkey but when
you get out because apparently when you
sit in other people's pee for a couple
of hours like that's not that great for
your skin it soaks in through your suit
and well Channel is just disgusting I
think that that is one of the drawbacks
of team racing when you have multiple
drivers in the lineup who have to share
a car together well it's more than the
other guys if you pee in your seat at
least if you pee it's your own pee so
people simply just go it doesn't happen
all the time it doesn't happen
frequently but it does happen often
enough that absolutely the consequences
is something that most race teams have
been a business for a while they know
all about hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday is that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favourite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront
is a massively disruptive and a good
'we set it and forget it investing
service led by technologists for places
like Apple and world-famous investors it
has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it
a client now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by 99designs
when your business is a logo website
business card thumbnail any other design
I recommend checking out 99 designs I
use them myself I've used them for many
years I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to becoming number one York
Times bestseller
I've also uses them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free and 9 million dollar upgrade on
your first design so check it out 99
designs dot-com forward slash 10
[Applause]